bien bonjour bienvenue sur des voies la
tv pour cette coupe du monde donc fi dès
2017 huitièmes de finale partie retour
donc on a vu cette partie extraordinaire
entre maxime vachier lagrave et donc
alexander great souk dans ce huitième de
finale dans la première partie la partie
allait ou maxime avec les bleus avec
avec les blancs dont cannes n'a pas
réussi à passer avec une défense
extraordinaire de creech look et une
énorme énorme attaque de maxime partie
vraiment à revoir
il ya des parties nulles qui qui parfois
sont bien meilleurs que dès que des
victoires
donc on va voir aujourd'hui la partie
retour c'est parti avec maxime donc avec
les noix et de 4 c 5 cavaliers f3 des
six c'est une défense sicilienne
caractériser un sur e4 par le coup c'est
5 le coup ici de ce pion ici qui
contrôle la casse des quatre des 4 pour
les blancs prise cavaliers prend donc on
a échangé un pion de l'ale compte
rupture centrale voilà c'est ça l'idée
dé nord cavaliers psy ce qu'avait laissé
3 à 6 donc c'est la grande variante
l'âge d'or fin avec l'a6 l'un des 6es
assises que qui était une des grandes
favorites de bobby fischer et de garry
kasparov à 4 g 6 donc là on rentre dans
une drague on en choisit de ne pas jouer
avec sur à quatre avec des plantes plus
standard on peut jouer aussi avec eux
s'ils sont peu joué qui avait 17 ans
plus jeunes beaucoup de choses adams et
7 etc voilà faut deux fous g7 et petit
robot film dragons mais avec donc bien
sûr le petit rôle puisqu'on a joué à 4
donc ce n'était pas pour faire le wok
sinon on aurait affaibli notre lda mais
on attaque contre le roi blanc aurait
été impuissante côté nord donc petit
rock fouet trois qu'avait laissé six et
d'amd 2 voilà les blancs prépa ans sans
doute déjà il lit les tours c'est
important la dame en finance que cette
case pour lier les tours où la case d3
où ils s'exposent quand même cavalier
sent-il attaque
et on peut aussi envisager d'aller
changer le foot g7 qui est quand même
fou puissant qu'une très bonne diagonale
devant lui voilà qui contrôle bien les
quinze mois et donc on peut souvent
l'échangé avec la tourbe évite de maxime
qui met sa tour on voit bien qu'ils
préparent éventuellement des cinq plus
tard
évidemment pour les stars les blogs
comptes ont très très bien mais celle ci
est le pion à cas tout cas laissé trois
lecavalier décalé beaucoup de pièces
quand même h3 là on évite toute
tentative de venir sur la case g4 que ce
soit par le foot le cavalier et puis on
fait une petite fenêtre pour le roi qui
file à la fin au camp comme plutôt quand
les colonnes s'ouvre qui peut éviter
ainsi le fameux mat du couloir tout 17
tours d un abcès celle de maxime et
cavaliers 3° tube avec et bien
proposition 2 nuls acceptez donc voilà
une partie très très courte
comme vous pouvez le voir qui se finit
extrêmement huit ans andy coût 10 onces
crous et le 11e coup là pour l'épauler
blanc donc qui propose nul sans doute
qu'il était est chaude et un par la
partie d'hier quand même il s'en est
sorti vivant nombre de justesse et il y
avait peut-être envie de se remettre de
ses émotions alexander reach ou qu il y
avait les blancs quand même et donc
possibilité d'essayer de passer mais
peut-être qu'il estime que tu en partie
rapide il a de meilleures chances que
maxime
ou que simplement il voulait se reposer
de toute façon le match reste ouvert
donc on aura droit d'aider partage en
partie rapide
j'en profite donc forcément pour
conclure ce résumé rapide de la partie
d'aujourd'hui de maxime parle annonce
est bien du fameux tournoi de chartres
voilà qui commence dans quatre jours au
moment où on enregistre cette émission
nous sommes en septembre 2010 est pour
ceux qui nous écoutera en 2018 2019 ou
au delà mais dans quatre jours voilà
christian bauer tête de série numéro 1
avec plus de 2800 il à 2820 je crois un
hello en partie rapide c'est tout à fait
colossal numéro 4 français champion de
france 2015 cette année un film
championnat de france exceptionnel s'est
un peu effondré sur la fin mai mais
sinon il était quand même
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
qu'il aurait pu il méritait peut-être
même le titre de champion qui finalement
été conquis de haute lutte un parent par
etienne bacrot mais voilà question qui
est en super forme et il va être présent
au tournoi de chartres il y aura aussi
la mine guliyev donc qui est un super
grand maître aussi qui écument un
général les parties les parties rapides
et n'est pas et les blitz ils aiment et
ils aiment beaucoup ça il est très fort
sur ses cadences là et il est entraîneur
à chartres voilà on peut aussi noter
donc pour info donc il s'agit d'un
tournoi sur deux rondes qui sera
retransmis sur des modèles tv
abonnez vous sur la chaîne diagonale tv
sûr sur youtube ou bien aller
directement sur le site officiel
diagonale tv.com où vous aurez les liens
vers le circuit à bonal tv et vous
saurez donc annoncé vous aurez des
annonces pour les prochaines direct ou
les prochaines émissions
donc il ya d'abord un tournoi de blitz
le 16 septembre 2010 cet espace tout il
donc ses lèvres mais c'est à côté de
chartres vous rappelle que chartres
c'est à peine une heure de paris donc
c'est la grande banlieue de paris donc
c'est une heure en train depuis depuis
les gares de paris donc c'est assez
facile à pour pour y aller et le club de
chartres extrêmement dynamique puisque
cette année il a organisé notamment le
top 12 qui est quand même le championnat
de france des clubs et avec un club très
dynamique un grand maître résidents
comme
un ami guliyev qui entraîne les équipes
et voilà qu'ils organisent aussi de très
beaux tournois rapide et qui pour la
première fois sera retransmis sur des
chaînes tv donc le bit le 10 16
septembre et donc le rapide qui aura
lieu le lendemain le 17 septembre le
dimanche
voilà avec donc
ouverture des inscriptions de 8h30 à
9h30 et début du tournoi vers vers 10h
cette ronde de 15 minutes plus 5
secondes alors que pour le buisson et à
11 rondes de trois minutes plus 2
secondes avec début prévu à 14 heures
voilà donc ça c'était pour le fameux
tournoi de chartres métropole voilà le
club le club phare de la ville et de la
métropole de chartres qui donc organise
aussi étonnant à laives charte relève
donc ce beau tournoi rapide et blitz en
transmission des ondes tv le week-end le
week-end prochain
voilà donc ça c'était pour terminer
cette ce petit résumé très rapide donc
de cette partie nulle et donc on aura
droit à des partages de même entre donc
maxime chine aggrave et alexander gris
tchouk au revoir à bientôt sur les
modalités nez